SPEAKER: Configuring
the Android Emulator
is easy with the AVD
wizard in Android Studio.
It offers default settings for
optimal Emulator performance.
If you want to double-check your
AVDS are configured correctly
and your machine can run
them with full hardware
acceleration, follow
these few steps.
First of all, check that your
CPU supports the required
virtualization extensions.
On Windows and Mac, only
Intel VTX is supported,
and the necessary virtualization
software from Intel
is available through the SDK
manager inside Android Studio.
On some machines, VTX
is disabled by default.
In that case, please refer
to your motherboard or laptop
manual on how to enable it.
If you're using Linux,
both the Intel VTX
and the AMDV
virtualization technologies
are supported through KVM.
In our documentation
pages, linked below,
we provide information
on how to check if KVM
is installed in your system.
Now that we have the most
difficult part out of the way,
let's go through the
AVD creation process.
On the first screen,
select a device skin
that you'd like to
use for development.
If you don't have
a high-end GPU,
you might benefit from
choosing a device with a lower
resolution.
You can always change the
size later by editing the AVD.
Next, choose the system image.
There are three important
guidelines for this step.
Choose one of the more recent
releases with a higher API
level number, as those
contain the newest fixes
and optimizations.
Mak, sure you're
selecting an x86 image,
and also one marked as
having Google APIs, which
means you'll be able to test
apps that make use of Google
Play Services or integrate with
some core apps such as Google
Maps.
On the last step, you can
select from different graphics
acceleration modes,
but leaving it on Auto
should detect your
GPU capabilities
and select the best mode to run.
If you're having
problems, it's best
to always make sure that
your graphics drivers are up
to date.
You can read more
about the various GPU
settings in our documentation,
also linked in the description.
If you encounter any bugs
when running the Emulator,
please read the Android
Studio bug finding process
and report them using
the Issue Tracker.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks for watching,
and if you want
to learn more about Android
Studio and Android development,
click on one of the videos here.